hey Steven I did a billion views while
you were still in diapers and no matter
how much you train I'll still eat you
for lunch your pal Chuck
hey I like the box
[Laughter]
[Music]
you know like Calgary
ran away
[Music]
which brings me to this piece steven
crowder is a self-styled comedian to get
into my head
silly liberal
[Music]
[Music]
your show you is you so we are
officially announcing the louder with
Crowder mug club for our daily program
time people are aware of how corrupt the
media is and there's a void and we are
going to take it back
there's you're listening to talk radio
strangest animal this is the
waterboarding Christmas telethon
spectacular and waterboarding has to be
done just properly by the way tinnitus
Crowder hijacks Shia
[Music]
YouTube CEO Susan watch its keep
[Music]
[Music]
there's no point in wondering where your
pockets are tasty
[Music]
there's no sense in wondering where your
pockets are
[Music]
and most importantly the funny is on our
side
YouTube dragged his feet before taking
any action against conservative
commentators steven crowder so then we
did announce the monetization change
that steven crowder was fox ad pocalypse
right now with a trending at number four
on incredible
dry
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
like sighs candy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that's called the Justin Bieber with a
heart murmur oh no wow physical
yesterday were they were testing for a
heart murmur
oh they don't answer when you do a
physical do I have it results Mike you
just listened to it yeah you know did
you record it with the stethoscope by
the way my half-asian lawyer bill
Richman is here quarterblack audio wait
is here
Gerald a is here what's the one in the
day we have Mountain beater cabernet
sauvignon mountain V T V del V del V tur
that's not a word it's it's not a word
it's not a real thing you're making
things up there I don't know why you are
still around is to keep men oh I know
listen guys we really appreciate this is
a it's the 1 billion view Joel yes
billion plays I want to go round of
applause for all you guys all not gerald
I do want to ask you will be showing
some videos I think some tweets going
into the break from you guys but what's
been your favorite moment with the show
in the last billion plays or how are you
introduced to the show I would like to
know we have some guests coming up we're
gonna have Donald Trump doing your Ted
Cruz Alex Jones James O'Keefe Marco gab
McGinnis John O'Hurley chill son and Dan
Crenshaw Jim Norton Anthony Kamiya
Andrew Clavin Rand Paul and my mood Alma
mood director of public relations for
Isis so they'll be calling still has a
job that still does have a job he's very
good at it he's working hard he's harder
than for showing us the softer side of I
hear the resumes out though I know that
by the way some of you will think this
is lazy really wants it we've used the
term clip show in the past and said
we're going to have some clips here from
our favorite moments a few montages and
also kind of give you a little bit some
inside baseball oh I didn't mention
promo code now if you enter in Crowder
billion I think for the next I know at
least for the next 48 hours it might be
a few days yes you get $20 off if you
join
was never meant to be let me say
something first really quickly Garret
quarterblack Garrett and audio Wade were
the ones who said we should do this show
I kind of floated the idea I didn't
really want to do the billion views show
we did the 1 million subscribers that's
enough of a benchmark maybe if we did
hit 10 million subscribers at some point
I don't want to be the guy who rests on
the laurels of how many people tuned in
or holy or something is well do that and
then they crumble because all of their
identity is based on this sort of
procedure and I just want to put my head
down and get to work but you mentioned
that it was more important not for us
yeah but it's for the fans it's for the
fame that's for me I'm a fan you know
it's I want to see all the old stuff and
remember hell yeah this is we've come a
long way and we abused you both
physically and all the time yeah a fan
but but within the bounds of the law yes
bamboo wood chips up the thumbnails and
I do so I am really grateful I do want
to let you guys know I'm so I really am
so grateful that you've been here for a
billion plays that you've made this what
it is you know you start from that
montage started back in 2006 on YouTube
and then really doing regular uploads
2009 that were more political I really
never anticipated it to get I shouldn't
say didn't anticipate it but I had no
idea that this show would become exactly
what it is I'm you know I know I feel
like I'm no I should say by the way this
is a billion what you guys will see
publicly we've we've actually crossed a
billion a long time yet but we had to
remove a bunch of videos because of the
Vox ad pocalypse fascist pricks
somewhere around a trillion I think now
well actually if you add up those who
are not in bug Club members a lot of
credit accomplished Michael if you add
up because we do a Daily Show there you
know so four times the content that you
get here on YouTube and then you add up
the website and crowd herb it's it's
actually closer to two billion but this
is last this channel yeah a billion
after all the videos had to be removed
still still making no money on those
billions right now right now
now it's yeah yeah you know plus or
minus zero zero making sure just add a
header above great business there's some
volatility in the market try and pick
monetization stocks we provide the long
ball and I assume that every ten years
we zero our money yeah yes that's not
unaffected by Corona oh well their
ability invest in silver dog month let
me kind of give you a little bit of a
briefer for people who don't know you
know I start off as a stand-up comedian
actor and really my first foray into
doing more political videos was a 2009 I
did work with PJ TV and then it was with
Fox News for four and a half years and
you know I they didn't really and god
bless him the person who's the president
at Fox News now Suzanne Scott I have
nothing but good things to say about her
she actually back then she was a VP
would go in an advocate advocate for me
oh thanks because all I knew when I was
at Fox was that Roger Ailes hated me but
then I found out that he hated Noor
McDonald so I took it like a badge of
honor for valid reasons he hated Noor
McDonald because he was crazy
um and nor McDonald didn't pass the
twirl test always shot from the right
and to then Scott was the one who went
in and advocated for me with Fox News
they didn't know what they wanted to do
with me the district they didn't want
anyone else to have me and so um I
wasn't super happy there like I was
being paid and I'm a very gruff before I
was appearing a few times a week and
writing articles but I always wanted to
be doing something like this and so
after that this show that you're
watching right now it really just
started off as a terrestrial radio show
out of Detroit and I went with them
because I said let me own 100% of the
rights yeah I didn't make a dime on
terrestrial radio for a long time it got
syndicated out to a bunch of markets and
then we started learning how to operate
a TriCaster and broadcasting from the
den and it just kept growing and growing
and and turned into you know what it is
now so I say this because sometimes you
may have dreams and if you're inflexible
you think you're giving up on them this
is so much better than anything I could
have anticipated
and I am genuinely grateful to be able
to do this it's a very very hard job
it's a lot of work but I do feel blessed
to be able to do this for you guys and
that you have rewarded us with with a
billion plays and because think about a
billion place is worth nothing if not
for the people watching it right yeah
absolutely like a billion scroll over it
like on Facebook and it counts as a play
that's like we have toilet paper so
apparently we're going where all yes
we'll have barter money and before we
get into the cinematic opens any of your
kind of favorite stories as far as uh if
I can jump in here I know bill might you
can't do it so you know a lot of people
don't understand success was never
guaranteed in this and in fact there
were a lot of moments that you had
throughout your career where you were
like I have no idea how this is gonna go
out and I remember one specifically I
can laugh at it now but I felt so
horrible we were having dinner I think
or lunch me you and Hiller and we were
talking about like yeah man I keep doing
this should I not keep doing I was like
look if you ever maybe for videos don't
get like 85,000 plays you should maybe
pick the career you just looked at me
like eighty-five thousand is actually
pretty good but I mean that at that
point you had no idea like you had a
desire for it a passion for it you knew
you could do something but you had no
idea how big it could possibly get and
you weren't assured of success nobody at
all that's also something that I really
love seeing is now there there are so
many younger people who are conservative
or or leaning right back then and that's
also we'll talk about a top seven seven
plus one a lot of credit controversies
over the years see if you can guess
which ones they are
that's what a lot of The Young Turks to
go after me and really you know smear me
today when I had thirty forty thousand
subscribers and they exactly we didn't
have the ability we didn't the firepower
to correct the record so it was it was
tough there were no conservatives out
there it was when edgy atheism and
liberalism dominated all of YouTube yeah
and it was a it's amazing how things
have change we don't know where we're
going but it really is it's been a crazy
ride when you think about yes yeah yeah
absolutely so what one of the funny
stories that kind of the
that it hit home about kind of the war
that you've had to fight with some of
the folks in traditional media was one
time I was on vacation we were doing a
copyright battle with Mashable and they
were insisting on trying to take one of
your videos down and I looked right at a
resort Mexico trying to deal with it and
we ended up getting it resolved and keep
in mind for those who don't know this
was back then it was a manual thing
where bill was actually filing paperwork
to counter a false claim
we're like saying hey you're gonna do
this you got to come sue us and the more
contact in YouTube and we're trying to
fight through that system and it was
that was the moment that I really
realized I was in a hotel room at this
resort in Mexico and I was thinking to
myself Oh what Stephens been saying
about the war and like what how this is
going on and I don't mean more in the
sense of you know what our soldiers are
doing and what our troops are doing but
I mean in the sense of the war for for
audience for eyeballs and ears and and
knowing that there is a place for comedy
and conservative you know yeah and what
and you know we were I mean that's how
we met was actually a man who was a
groomsman at my wedding he's a Harvard
lawyer but I was like oh you're a lawyer
and actually Ben Shapiro negotiated my
Fox contract hey you have a good last
name for a lawyer and I remember our our
buddy said well this is not the kind of
law I do but you might want to call my
buddy bill that was it Engadget Gizmodo
you know and that's where the article
came out that someone who worked at
Facebook long before the leaks was like
James O'Keefe in project very test
someone just leaked this memo that was
at Facebook that people were basically
putting code into pages to throttle and
shut down some pages and it was Ted this
was Ted Cruz for president Fox News
Breitbart bribers Kyle Foundation and
then me I was like hey I don't want to
over blow this but I sent it to Bill and
I remember I was at a hotel at that
point yeah and you just call back you're
like yeah this is not like I'm good I'm
reading this and I remember looking at
the other ones I'm like I know all these
other ones but who is this guy targeting
we were so much smaller yeah and I think
it's just because we were always pretty
effective with the content because we
were unique and because you guys have
been so supportive I mean we can't you
know we'd love to do live shows we
we don't have the ability to do them
because you fill up every venue and it
becomes a secure yarn you and supportive
demonetised you guys have made up yeah
with mug club you know when you guys
have joined and obviously I have the
entire blaze catalog and it's just every
time that we think oh we're going off a
cliff the Vox ad pocalypse you guys came
in and not only saved us but supported
us more than before yeah absolutely I
know I sound like a broken record but I
cannot thank you enough sometimes
artists go out and something I'm just
gonna do this I'm just gonna do this for
me
it's self-important it's bull crap if I
create art that is of only a value to me
I am valueless there is no use for what
I do I want to create content that is
enlightening entertaining for you and we
always try to listen you guys we really
do appreciate it and since we've grown
and I hope you guys have seen this
directly since you've joined up at Mudd
Club at $69 for students veterans or
military just so you know something it's
a little bit steep and right now
everyone gets $20 off we've increased
production value and we've increased
overall volume of content yes and so
this brings us to our first montage when
we first started you know was a radio
show yeah we would do these fake little
audio commercials because it was at
restoration we had 12 commercial breaks
so good go back but I would just with at
that point not gay Jerrod and just go
alright here's an idea the Swiss Family
Robinson second generation and I would
do an audio sketch about a bunch of
inbred kids we found out we violated the
law horribly but it was okay because
only on podcast we do the fake warnings
like Lena Dunham warnings Velociraptor
warnings and I don't know like this is
highly illegal you know this might dude
it's not a podcast it's an archive
whoever thinks it's a live warning is an
idiot okay but you should stop doing it
so we did stop doing it right so we have
these 12 commercial Brits we just have
to fill because the podcast and we
didn't want you watching come on down to
Ann Arbor Ford if Salani forward where
will if we don't give you the best price
we're just gonna give it to you subject
my listeners to that so I'll do
pedophile parodies of Michael Jackson
classics
these into the commercial breaks and
then after the controversy of never
daily which will get seven plus one
controversies and you guys joined up at
my club we realized a lot of these ideas
that we had we could now do yeah and so
we were able to do not only more on
location videos which are incredibly
labor intensive but but these big intros
that you guys have really come to
appreciate and kind of expect where
sometimes are some pressure but it keeps
us on our toes so this is actually
before we'll come back with our 7+1
controversy start the history of letter
with credit right now I want you to
enjoy a montage of throughout the years
the best or your favorite that you
tweeted me at S Crowder cinematic or TV
parody opens sir my name is steven
crowder and these here are the Mudd Club
Z's from Liederkranz late-night comedy
of salvation to south of Seoul and we
here you might have a platform for us to
upload our videos do well that out of
hand you boys do conservative videos
it's seen
[Music]
drinking system Thomas antenna with
motor does me uploading sort videos me
talking to my camera
[Music]
my then diem turns used to make like
minutes for me
they tease me quite a bit edgy how many
subscribers you got on YouTube son when
you crossed over that in 1 million mark
you are beautiful a fun way to stop your
condom not a verb but right when you hit
that three million subscriber month no
never
okay four million subscribers I will hit
four million I was always going to hit
four million
[Music]
funny we were demonetized before that
broadcast even went blind
so what happens Jake we go gets direct
support from you to what do I get a
one-way ticket the D monetization bill
it's not even manual rejected for
monetization there's no way they can
review it that fast safe to the YouTube
all the rhythm s advanced beyond all
comprehension over 600 videos in the
channel all of them restricted in less
than 12 minutes YouTube's new policies
have been so secret no email
notifications had been sent throughout
my news have come to realize there are
seven words you cannot ever ever say on
YouTube and these words [ __ ] cheap
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] and mesogens
yesterday those are the words and
Moakler might be more necessary than
ever because YouTube has become a
liberal let me show you boys are real ad
I'm not over - Regina gordita some
people think he's a Mexican he's half a
thanks to her funding from my club those
false plaintiffs have pulled their hard
strikes again right on time
- the second they always do I buy them
for you
and we win every time I hear you boys
ordered a half asian ass-kicking
Richmond I don't want no go fund me I
don't want no patreon too many damn
whining conservatives on this platform
$10,000 remain my half a bill Richman by
ourselves we tank what gets hurt or seen
on YouTube jihad is already won
we shall part only YouTube
all the Twitter the instagrams we should
fight with
and Dean monetized
and there we go now it's not slowly a
clip show it's not only a clip show but
you know sometimes a billion views you
are you take a break a little gosh it's
a volume of how many days and nights
that we've worked on these yeah so
what's your what's your favorite of the
montage is the intros that you I'm sorry
montage the intros that we've done even
I favor to the mom yeah gosh it's tough
to pick the my favorite probably it
still goes back to John's the first
choice because that was the first thing
we ever did yeah and I said you know and
I think I can work on this impression
and the the green screening the lighting
was really good we met I'm a big fan of
matching tenor and tone that was up
there Raging Bull and you know the
recent Saving Private Ryan was
technically kind of a kind of a Marvel
yeah so I was very very nice I like I
like you when Maddie dies in them any of
any of them she blows up I'm just
kidding to cue Maddie I'm just kidding
how many times did I ask you to put on
an outfit we're gonna say oh you know
it's funny as I tell people all the time
they're like oh wow I can't believe you
like did that on the show alright don't
you like have another job
and I said yeah for now but no I said
you know this body like that the other
thing the other things that are asked of
me and I'm just like nope not gonna do
that I think we're like 13 27 times
you've asked me to wear a dress on yes
yeah I think that's why I ended up in a
dress so many times is because he said
no and I well you because you made such
a big deal film you bitching about
wearing it oh you never actually put
actually requested intimacy Gerald in a
dress it's just our security cameras
that we keep running ah a man like a
Tupac hologram yeah
speaking of strolls down memory lane I
think this is time to actually go
through the top seven plus one
controversies that have happened here on
louder with Crowder so let's go to it
seven plus one alright and let me know
before you watch positive it's an
archive let me know which ones come to
mind for you I guess kind of starting in
chronological number seven would be the
the Union incident lanta so before this
show existed but when I was on Fox News
and I went down and it was a
right-to-work rally yeah and we were in
a tent there was this tent was AFP and I
was just there because you know there's
somewhat safety in numbers yeah and the
guy there there was a sky you could
smell whiskey on his breath told
everyone that I was developed the
divorces grandson like I'm related to
the DeVos family Betsy DeVos because
they these leftists in Michigan they
hated DeVos family despite the fact that
they employ half the state yeah well
above a living wage oh darn you employ
me so he was trying to get everyone
against me for a while--and son get him
get him and then they started kicking
down the tent where the right-to-work
pro protesters were in yeah cutting in
with box cutters and this guy tripped
over a tent peg and I got just
sucker-punched you guys have probably
seen this people often send it like on
Twitter like it bothers me like now I
remember I was punchy G was I the reason
that was a controversy that was because
the guy fell got up punched me and then
I just sort of walked away and then the
rumor started it was the Young Turks I
believe who started it that I had shoved
him first right because you know when I
got when you shove a guy he falls this
way India the prosecuting or where with
the prosecuting attorney I guess in the
in Lansing never took there was a
deposition I didn't know about it I was
never there he met with the head of the
unions and Michigan did it without me
and said it was pretty clear from the
young turks footage they didn't have
footage it was their commentary footage
that just even started it so I let the
guy go common for like a deposition like
that for me to not know not be there and
my evidence tonight accepted it's
uncommon it's not common that you would
have been there for it to happen it is
uncommon that they didn't come and ask
you for it it's clear that they were
looking for an answer
they found one thing to support it and
they
just moving on and and so this became a
big thing I remember the thing and the
most frustrating part for me just as
your friend because at that point I
don't think I was very involved with a
child calling every once in a while it
was just like I know Stephen could have
kicked that guy's ass without even
thinking about it like but you were in a
mob be not a people well the thing is
you hear if you go if you go if you
watch it I think of the b-roll and you
can't hear right now there's a guy
saying uck I have a gun okay with a gun
yeah that's a guy that's a union guy and
I might be able to maybe I can find some
of this footage but several of them
followed me back to my car
yeah walk in front of me yeah and I
think that was the guy who said I'll
kill a mother with a gun yeah so this
just was before anti-fur before black
lives matter yeah I was the original the
knockout game only I didn't go down and
then I ran scared because they said they
were gonna kill the mother in question
yes that was the first time I ever had
some sort of a national story today yeah
yeah and that's that's uh number six do
you member that remember this one there
quarterblack Garrett Wendy Davis
yeah woman's March Jude now so that was
before we became pills no no no this is
this is I felt like it was a moment
where you guys should have been pals
right yeah well we were kindred spirits
we got an interview with Wendy Davis at
the women which is awesome the reason
why you know why we just had a producer
up and say hey we can interview I'm busy
she's trans yes sure absolutely came out
and the reason I picked this do you
remember cuz when he did is Texas they
were grooming her for a national royo
yeah right so with their tennis shoes
and the whole deal I was going to be
then that sort of like Elizabeth Warren
or Debbie wasserman-schultz who failed
miserably in an electric yeah right but
I think a big reason for so if you watch
this yeah you can see this right now
says the women's March only got an
interview because I claimed to be
transgender and that's why we started
using Stephanie under anything
no one will say a word it's hot at a
Planned Parenthood for pregnancy
by the way if a man pees test positive
for a pregnancy as I did at Planned
Parenthood means you have testicular
cancer yes so they didn't say that but
Wendy Davis there's a moment right here
here we'll play the trainer where you
can see it if you see my hat blows off
in the wind and my wig shifts and I
thought the jig is up
there sure she's just like I said it's
okay it happens to the best of us Mike
it does she never won any sort of
elected office again after that because
I think that if she were to run for
president even some national office but
yeah okay well we do see your record we
do see this pamphlet on the issues is
this not you with a trainee at the
woman's mark with his wig and cap flying
on discussing the economics I quote
economics and there were all these
articles about it and house meeting and
that was one was like yes it was awesome
because you can put her in a corner she
can't do anything against you like
you're the whole wig could have come off
you could have started talking like a
man again and she'd just be like I can't
I can't not believe you she would have
been done oh yeah there's just they just
they give you all kinds of cover oh just
clean up fun because they say well you
know what you're a marginalized group
okay I guess that's fine I can just just
go out and commit we don't have this
number five yes right this is number
five this was and you were with we I was
working with you at that point this was
undercover antiphon yeah and this was
one where it actually led to the arrests
of people did which is funny because the
media coverage said no arrests were made
right not only were arrests made they
were made based on the weapons that was
handed to my producer on camera earlier
that day we went down there was a ben
shapiro show in utah for people who
don't remember and you didn't go with us
right we were know was before my time it
was well had you worked intermittently
with us yo yeah okay i came and worked
in before and then you came back and
yeah and my I know my my dad went down
with me because we all didn't
going to this this uh yeah this quagmire
and obviously not Cory was with me and
and we went down and they handed not gay
Jared we thought it'd be funny ice pick
he said oh this and a knife hole just
hold on I'm over here my sawed-off
shotgun he's like yeah
Sierra does that it was a really Jerry
rigged earpiece it was an iPhone with
like a headphone thing so yeah oh here's
him don't like giving me giving me
knives and I'm sure if they heard is
your piece they were just here but did
you just say they're giving you knives
they're going to get a sawed-off shotgun
they're going to get a sock a bar did
you just say K boy
but yeah okay you think you want me to
stay if we go you have to get out of
there just to get out of there and we
sure I don't know okay hold on hey guys
[Laughter]
usual for him no no not at all and so
then after that we're thinking I texted
Ben Shapiro well thank you and they were
trying to stab me with a k bar muggy
you're welcome just saved you like I
told him I did tell him I said right
away hey be careful he came in the back
way and then we were dealing with local
police right there so the local police
said what do you have to have this
fridge we said yeah we had brought in
our laptops yeah there was local news
there and I said hey do you guys want
this footage because I know you're
covering the protests here here is the
action was shown at them look this is
the actual footage see they're handing
him a knife they're handing him a Taser
they're saying that they're going to get
started off shot this is on camera yeah
every single local reporter turned it
down had no interest I said by the way
says legitimate we're going into the
police van right now to offload the
footage you can have the exclusive and
with Ben Shapiro that that day was um
that reporter from what was his name
they're doing do we know the name that
report from 60 minutes they had a panic
attack live on air remember the name of
this
that guy all right so want to bring it
up and give it to me up there anyways
national news and he was looking at it
and we said look look look they're
handing us a knife right here that
looked in a Taser and he goes like okay
and then afterward we saw them all doubt
and say a largely peaceful protest
exactly right tonight the girl who
handed us the Taser and we gave him a
Grover tase somebody with that weapon
and was arrested and then we sent on the
because we got into their cryptic
messaging app yeah we sent them just us
going like this given the and I swear to
you the girl who was arrested for using
that taser was going you better give my
knife back my evidence back good luck
yeah was basically you know peaceful
everybody thought they were people
assess yeah it wasn't just that he was
going back to get a shotgun it was I
have a fallback position right things go
down we can like fall back to my car I
have multiple guns there right like it
was it was like it wasn't in Patriot
where you're running back yeah or
robbing but then they come up in like
the dirt trap people in bandanas who are
gender non-binary and the guy who turned
the story down is Dan Harris yeah the
10% heavier guy was arrested and I was
just this was something to me I learned
and the reason I picked these initially
the Union issue and this I learned
really quickly that the media doesn't
care about truth no they really really
dump it listen you can argue okay some
people on the the far-right are
aggressive and then some people in the
far left and they're fringe but they
weren't arguing that like I said they
were arguing anti-fur as a peaceful
organization and like Vox there was in
their anti-fascist that's all it is yeah
if it's a crime it's a serious crime
serious crimes were committed people
were arrested and it was not a peep so
thank you guys so much because we got we
got tens of millions of plays on them
and it was covered that never would have
happened if not for mug club because we
would have never been able to afford
going out there and bringing a crew and
certainly would have never been able to
afford uploading this and having the
staff to do it like that's something
that I think changed the view of
antiphon and
a champion our own cause saying hey
we're the ones who exposed anta foe but
it really was the first undercover sting
that showcase them to be not only as
violent as they were but the top story
was the fact that the media wanted it to
not be a story exactly this next one is
very much as 3/4 4/4 or force win buzzer
aw Bob Ross system yeah this is the
retainer yes
now did you do a you were new here but
when did you start watching the show I
started so I think the first thing I
ever saw was the undercover Muslim
bakery oh yeah that was just meat with
an iPhone yeah it was so I I remember
watching that and talking about the
sting like it was it was sort of like an
undercover thing but it was also funny
it was so in talking about work time but
earlier it was so different from
anything else that I was seeing because
it was obviously like a right-wing video
but it was entertaining and felt like it
felt like news but it also was we
weren't looking for a lawsuit ready to
entertain people yeah yeah look at this
like clears like hey I don't think
Muslims should have to bake a penis cake
right you do I appreciate that because I
used I've always conservative and you I
think the approach you know I was like
hey you know what you have a case here
you should sue Mike first off I'm not
looking to sue I'm looking to create
content now grace of our show let's say
we're throttled were unfairly treated
different that's where if you look at
the options of being litigious but we
can't just go out looking for
controversy and just right we always
seek to create content and they're a
Muslim and the hypocrisy was so funny
yeah culture it was all about that that
bakery yeah it was a perfect time to
drop that I remember you balls the
Muslims are very friendly and saying no
or yeah yeah I'm like in two men and
they're holding hands no
[Laughter]
so did you see the Bob Ross the original
one I think I I don't think I did okay
so I yeah this is the greatest it's the
greatest video ever well this is a good
example of you know we were doing a
three-hour show this was bad was a radio
show it was bizarre the first Bob Ross
sketch you can just see some b-roll here
a little bit and then you can go and
watch these clips and watch you toss to
the final clip so we it was just an idea
this isn't in the middle of a three-hour
show we didn't upload it as a clip I
don't think for a while it was just hey
let's do Bob Ross it might have been
after Charlie Hebdo I'm not sure I might
have just wanted I guess people often in
a while thank you yeah that is Fox
Wallace I was about to say did you [ __ ]
my expire and wanted to re-up or what
and so we just did that we threw it into
the three-hour show meaning Bob Ross as
Mohammed thought that that was it well
that was not it was very big and then we
did it a second time oh yes there was
time I remember Nick DiPaolo was on that
show god Nick DiPaolo one of the
funniest people on earth yeah but we
were do we had a thumbnail and it's a
picture of me Nick DiPaolo and the
Mohammed painting yeah just get a phone
call sorry the sensor button today I get
a phone call ringing like Nick DiPaolo
remember I was driving I was driving in
downtown Grand Rapids I was going to a
coffee place what was a coffee place I
can't remember it was ah madcap and then
I got another call from it appalling
hell that's what two calls maybe it's an
emergency pick it up hello oh yeah do
you mind you know you talented you got
balls but yeah me next are you kidding
me a picture right up there next to a
painting of Mohammed you know you're no
stranger to controversy yeah but there's
some context
next to the next to Mohammed that's like
a change but I'm not home it's gonna
take me a couple hours they get home
nothing happened
yeah nothing on the legal side and then
there was BuzzFeed boldly painting in
period black people featured on YouTube
front page yeah and I think we spoke
with some people at YouTube and I think
they did something that was something
that was also religious it was something
with Christ there's a piss Christ and I
don't know what it was so we said well
okay now this is happening and we
brought back Bob Ross to paint Mohammed
in menstruation in this because they had
featured it from BuzzFeed boldly what we
said well let's add a different layer to
this and that was a problem
it's always the layering that gets us in
trouble Hamid layer not long after this
we receive a letter we receive an actual
letter yeah right and you tell them what
the letter was it was from yes oh it was
from the estate of Bob Ross the rights
to his likeness and his materials and
whatnot and they were upset over
painting and the content every minute
and second I think they were very
interested in demanding that we take it
down and they listed out some legal
arguments which we responded to one of
them was also that as you know is a
flagrant disregard for Islamic law and
customs
yes yes so it was that there was a
couple you know legal arguments about
copyright and some other you know use of
likeness and a few other things so we
wrote I knew we were in the clear on
that yeah yeah we were good on that
stuff yeah I mean we knew you know there
maybe have been some you know social
mores that we were crossing but
certainly no legal lines so you knew
that you knew that when you signed up
for this right anyway right front we're
fine right oh yeah yeah you're fine but
you probably shouldn't paint [ __ ]
period but my god doesn't mat that's not
that's not your domain that's not the
question for you Lloyd fine any lawyer
to tell me no I want you to show me yes
it's like the Jerry Maguire yeah exactly
and so we responded
you know tore apart their arguments you
know show why there was just no way it
was gonna happen so they wrote back
again and they said you know just if you
have any human decency
take it down they gave up on the legal
arguments they gave up on the social
more arguments but they were still
pretty jerky because they were telling
me that I didn't have any decency yes
yeah that is why so and this is one of
the times where said hey half-asian bill
and i think now if i were to ask you
would dress up as bob ross now because
you dressed up as tattoo bob ross is
nothing the first request r/a said will
you respond as bob ross and he said no
no i think i think i will always be
happy to be bob ross what I'm painting
is Bob Ross that's a I think one of my
favorite conversations with Bill I've
had is he's looking at a script that I
wrote and he's going through it silently
and then yeah I'm not gonna lick my lips
[Laughter]
it was in like one change was like Stan
Stan Stan Stan lick lips I was like new
who am i Drake am i doing am I doing
this
no I'm not doing it but you know they
wrote back you know we wrote back in
response to that last letter they were
like please just like take it down and
in the kind of a snarky ER part of the
letter I just said if you've if you've
ever watched the show you know we're not
going to final communication were then
we responded by video and that is where
it could be a fission bill said he
wouldn't dress up as Bob Ross but I
think it was more so that he didn't want
to be involved in painting said legal
representatives as Bob Ross eating from
a pile of corn infested yes this is the
moment was like this show
mohamad we just toss it in there and
here is actually a clip to the grand
finale of the Bob Ross controversy
[Music]
welcome back to the joy of painting I'm
Bob Ross now painting can be used as
more than just that's something that's
beautiful to look at it can be used to
express oneself sometimes it can be used
to express frustration tranquility or
sometimes gratitude as we'll be doing
today expressing gratitude in response
to some passionate fan mail we've
received we have a lot of different
viewers here at the joy of painting some
viewers are policemen some are firemen
and some are lawyers will be responding
to today who have talked about the show
with great vigor than Bob Ross is in
violation of copyright law so we want to
respond to them and make sure they know
they're welcome on this program so you
can grab your pallet today we'll be
working with a lot of Browns a lot of
Browns the beauty of Brown here is you
can mix it with any color and it's a
different Brown become a bait or a taupe
for a passionate lawyer friend we're
gonna start by drawing a pile of she
just was little short strokes there you
go it's a little starts off as a
molehill
and turns into a mountain just a big ol
mountain and there we go just a valley
of piping-hot will mix up some color add
some red and air it'll make a little bit
more of a cocoa flavoring at that point
give it some depth and now we're gonna
move into portrait mode and painter
lawyer friend who sent us the fan mail
falsely notifying us of a violation of
copyright and there's our lawyer like a
gazelle at a familiar watering all
bending over on all fours to eat from
our steaming hot pile of [ __ ] let's draw
a few lawyers I'm sure with a firm they
have some lawyer friends I'm still going
with brown you can use
any color you like taupe or sand depends
in the diet
here's another lawyer and there you go
the lawyers or sent out in droves on
YouTube to flag his violations eating
from our firm but corn and fasted pile
of [ __ ] Wow there you go everyone's
everyone's sharing there's plenty of
this pilot to go around for the entire
firm if you feel that there's not enough
you can wait your turn
there's plenty of room for you to eat at
this big old mountain of [ __ ] and there
we go oh that's lovely
and you know what we're a big fan of
traditions here at the joy of painting
with Bob Ross and they look like they
could use a friend so let's finish this
up with a nice little portrait of
Mohammed joining them and even from this
big old pile of [ __ ] there he is
Mohammed holiest of prophets peace be
upon him with the team false trademark
flagging lawyers eating from a big pile
of personally drawn ich bin for me to
you I'm Bob Ross happy painting and god
bless you my friend
[Music]
ya know like I get that sharks of
YouTube but we can be a pufferfish in
that that is true you Vitus your mouth
or even if you capture us and you kill
us and you cook us up some we're gonna
poison you one way or the other either
way safe really it's all coming up
Crowder so number three we could move
that this one we don't really need to go
through for that long it was the ABC
disney oscars yeah that was pulled yeah
yeah and the reason this was pretty
significant was because we had been
dealing with false copyrights definitely
yep yeah and what happened was we would
have all these claims we've never lost
any of those hard claims and the system
now but back when they used to actually
have to file a claim and you would
manually count your file yeah not a
single one have we ever lost Kate to be
clear but then they realized sure
there's a two-week process but then the
video ultimately gets up they realize
they could hit us with live streams yeah
because at that point you lose those
viewers you never get him back and this
was the second or third year we were
doing the honors it wasn't the first
year yeah the second and it was ABC
disney and they were waiting because it
happened very quickly where the oscar
stream was taken down yeah right away
and I reason I bring this up is because
obviously it got up later we won this
because we were in the right but you
don't get those years back and so we
were really upset but so many of you so
many people in that moment you joined up
at mug Club you went right to the crowd
it was like great and then we had I
think we had live stream over do we have
that mug club or was it the blue have
live streaming I don't think at the know
we dread it was still on Facebook it was
we went to Instagram so just with my
cell phone and the amount of viewers was
shocking so not only did you watch but
once it was removed you guys said you
know what I'm going to sign up so many
people actually a double signed up
yeah renewed their subscriptions for
three years yeah just because they saw
the foul play and it was just something
where we said oh wow okay we really know
it was a moment that the fans and people
that are watching saw it in real time
yeah yeah they saying it later or you
know like oh we got we got this taken
down we're losing monetization on these
videos yeah and that's something that's
kind of like in the ether almost today
right but they saw it in real time as
they're watching a show us get taken
down yeah I think it was
my son is is the the tip of the iceberg
is where people are finally seeing with
the problems and they actually had a
moment to glimpse the entire ice right
yeah not just the little part that they
see when we talk about it here and
asking for support for my club and the
very best fans in those moments stepped
up and yeah you know every time we talk
about mug club and what mug Club does
like literally the show cannot happen
this because you see what service we
said we only want to be funded by you
and a few select sponsors which we'll
get to in a minute we've really only can
I talked about the sponsors that have
dropped us no I do that as a turning
point too because you know people can
use a gimmick like oh they're after us
man you gotta support us you're the only
way and I know that we tell them like
hey guys like this is the only way that
this exists is if you are a part of Mudd
Club yeah that showed everybody yeah it
showed them just you know like you said
live but it also gave them this feeling
of like oh my gosh if if they want to
take conservative voices off of this
play can yeah they can just do stuff
like this to them they'll just somehow
they'll figure out a way and so we've
got to get around they really screwed
the pooch with that one because you know
the big legal term you can tell I guess
educate the audience is whether the
content is transformative right so the
fair use question is are you
transforming the underlying copyrighted
content and there's a few other factors
and transformative being one of the
bigger ones and of course you know over
the you know commenting on an event
that's occurring and you've assumed he's
gonna set oh man yeah yeah I think was
like 12 percent the actual Oscar stream
was up for 12% oh yeah I'm right it was
so tiny percentage yeah yeah so and then
you guys got us back up and stronger
than ever okay this brings us to number
two this is one that many of you may
have forgotten about because it had a
lot a little kernel issues that went on
with there where we had some other
internal counsel who are saying that we
shouldn't do this in the first place
yeah once it's built at my side Rison no
no you can do this if you don't okay
numbers number two when we were sued by
Shia LaBeouf context
and Mohammed hey hey you know the the
the your bearing the lead here we beat
that's true yeah so he did the he will
not divide us you remember after Donald
Trump became president just hmm
well not divide us he well not divide us
and so he set up this camera in a public
space in New York outside of some kind
of art museum space for anyone or go and
say he will not divide us and so really
okay so this is up there this is a
stream that's up there not many people
were watching it but it was yeah you
know making some headlines and so I said
hey I have an idea how about we go to
New York and we broadcast our entire
show from Shia LaBeouf string with mug
Club and what you guys do that support
us anyone could just go there and go
listen a lot of conservatives do they
ask you for money on patreon or on a
GoFundMe and then they just go out and
say something incendiary no he said how
can we actually we started with we
wanted to build the entire set bring it
out and set up right and then I think
legally we said that would actually be
impeding traffic in a public space it
might be a failure so this is why I love
half-asian bill because he said that's
probably a no but what if and so what we
did was we created these sort of almost
like a snare drum sound boards like a
cigarette lead yeah yeah and a desk with
a microphone and mugs and we went there
to Shia LaBeouf slideshow and broadcast
our entire show and also God loved him
Dean Cain was there an extra day so that
while we were doing that he will not
divide us live stream and now we start
having fans flooding in right yes
security and officers when what's going
on here we have Dean Cain Cain Cain I'm
Shia LaBeouf's he will not divide us a
note from Dean Cain Dean Cain is the
kind of guy who makes you very sad
because he's so he's just he has
everything he's very good-looking he's
very smart and when you spend time with
him you realize he's actually really
quick and kind of kind of an acid
he's an acid-tongued asian oh wow at one
point I just remember this I have a
necklace mug and microphone and I'm sit
we're in a Mexican restaurant it's right
around the corner it will not divide us
and I'm getting ready and Dean Cain is
sitting there with me and he's eating he
isn't
welcome all he's on a second bowl of
guacamole big ass margarita it looks
like pink with salt around the rim and
I'm trying you know before the show I'm
focusing on a million different things
I'm about to go out I'm gonna get my ass
kicked by Shia LaBeouf and so I mean you
know like body shots yeah and I go oh
wait wait I'm sorry Dean Dean I'm sorry
I didn't realize no one's here to with
you at the restaurant
because you're gonna be here for 20
minutes when we start the show do you
need me help you do anything and he goes
no I are real are you sure he goes yeah
you know I'm sure he takes a nacho
guacamole cinnamon margarita good
[Laughter]
so if you remember the beginning of the
livestream when you were doing it there
are actually some people who are not
fans of the show didn't know the show
came right and you were giving them mugs
and they were the day before yeah that
was we went down we gave them mugs full
of coffee and hot chocolate so all these
people aren't Shia LaBeouf stream going
like yeah shout out to laden with crowd
of guys again with mug Club you guys
should join he's just so pissed
well that's right got pissed and right
away they basically came after us to sue
us it was just LaBeouf Ronco Turner I
think was a firm or whatever and it was
I think the lesser LaBeouf oh there it
was wrong yeah it's the other Creators
they you know they each share in the
right copyright and he was threatening
to sue yeah and of course we won we
argued that it was transformative but
the reason was really upset was because
it was the highest view portion ever I
think he will not divide us livestream
is a spike
well yes stop we got to put a stop to
this and then after that that's what
spurred they moved that he will not
divide us to other places and all these
people on reddit oh yeah I guess back
then fortune would triangulate where
they set up the new camera and they it
just became a game of taking it down
yeah yeah it was like yeah so it was a
pretty it was it was good so you know
we're sued by Shia LaBeouf his guys and
we won number one and we have a plus one
but number one should be no surprise to
anyone of this is really in the last
this last year
the number-one controversy that we've
had here at lattice Crowder is you know
the vox ad pocalypse boom yeah and I
think I want to get all of your thoughts
on this here and I want you to let me
know where you were what you remember
from the box had pocalypse I mean we had
talked a lot about being demonic we had
most of our videos have been D monetized
we've been told where our videos weren't
showing up in 90% of videos right but
that being said we didn't have this kind
of a consequence ever no more and it all
of a sudden burst out this highlight
reel hit real on me however the
hodgetwins saying that they were like
yeah yeah I've seen you and your dad you
are Don Lemon show going and god lemon
saying disgusting
and this actually the reason this is the
biggest controversy is not only because
you guys stepped up and again supported
us to agree that that we had never seen
up until the same but this changed
policy for you yeah because we did not
violate the policies which by the way
New York Times we're looking for that
retraction we coming for to jewel we
didn't violate any policy at all but
people were so met and people really
weren't mad it was a leftist hate mob
right yeah I'm trying to go after us
they demonetized us and even though
almost her videos didn't run afoul of D
monetization and I will tell you this
I've talked about this kind of on-air
but not so much when YouTube called
after this was going on the highlight
reel and it was you know trending
everywhere yeah and that was in the
phone half-asian bill was not with me
you were somewhere else and they they
were reading a statement remember yeah
it was from YouTube faceless nameless
they didn't give names with no idea who
they were well just be clarify we asked
for their names and they said they felt
uncomfortable yes and identifying who
they were these people giving the
message yes
and they started reading a statement and
the first portion of the statement read
like they were going to remove our
channel from YouTube yeah and then it
and but then it ended up being we're
just going to do monetize you alright
we're not making that much money from
you guys anyway right but at first for
about a good twenty three seconds I said
oh no oh no gonna have to switch because
these angry gay folks at Vox are trying
to manipulate policy and I remember the
room started spinning and my knees went
out and I
I thought I was having heart attack
really I thought I was having it turns
out it wasn't like a I don't ever think
was a panic attack I don't know what a
I've sort of had panicked issues before
in the past but this was actually I just
felt like I couldn't breathe and the
room was spinning yeah and I fell back
and I was thinking just oh my gosh if it
works for us what are we gonna do at
this point because we hadn't really been
super public about it we hadn't fought
back yet
yeah this is before we've done the
apology video so I was thinking if they
just remove our channel then it goes
away in the dark you know we wanna does
nobody know I fight in public and then
when they said okay or just II monetize
I mean that way for me was a relief like
commercial or someone just shoved one in
my mouth which by the way don't do
someone's having a seizure doesn't
matter if he's having a seizure and
remember we came back in and I came back
into the room I don't think you guys
knew how rattled it wasn't I said okay
this is what we're gonna do and we did
the apology video that was 16 minutes of
insulting everybody what's going through
all of our most offensive jokes and we
even threw some new ones in there for
good measures and gifts yeah we just be
careful and you guys joined up so much
to the point where when you to focus
efforts gun did you use YouTube
memberships we said no like you know
vice news they reported that the whole
thing just made the show stronger yes
did yeah it made it a whole lot stronger
we had more subscribers than ever you
guys said it and by the way there could
be another Vox ad pocalypse but this is
what really stood out to me this was the
first time that someone had done an
all-out assault make no mistake this was
something that was a long time in the
making
yeah the Vox and Media Matters hardly
produced they pulled all of the worst
things they could pull him everyone The
Young Turks New York Times I sign off
was Samantha be some of the late night
hosts they all wanted to make me out to
be this monster which makes it you sent
more people to our show this was the
first show that had that happened and we
won and we weren't D platform you know I
will say this there have been unjust ii
platforming that we've gone in and we
can't do it for everybody but we all
general rule is unless someone is
breaking the law they shouldn't be d
platforming okay right yeah but it was
it was one of those things where I
forgot what I was about to say but I
think I think this was probably
for me because I was on the outside
because a lot of people don't know I
don't I don't stay around the studios
all day I come in for the shows we do
got up and some stuff I was on the
outside looking in and I was really
concerned because I started seeing stuff
happening on Twitter before I had got a
chance to talk to you guys I was like oh
gosh like this guy's really going after
us and I wasn't worried that he was
upset I was worried that everybody
seemed to be kind of like yeah this is a
bad like big players were coming around
him I'm like oh my gosh yeah to try to
take the show down and not to mention
that Vox was invested in by NBCUniversal
right one of the media conglomerates
ever and they did they're the ones who
put on the recode conference where Susan
Wojcicki was talking about yet right and
right plan framing it as though a
violent they consistently tried to frame
it as though we had violated policies
and even Susan would just get to
accredit was like they didn't violate
policies but it's borderline and I hate
and I hate the fact obviously we weren't
looking to change policy so that more
content is borderline and a lot of
non-political channels were affected but
not only did our audience come to our
defense but also the entire YouTube
community and people who hate me
rightfully so yeah I saw I saw a ton of
people that were like I'm not even
political I don't watch political stuff
right but I'm gonna go become a mud
clubber because this is messed up like
yeah not right I thought that was a
really exciting thing is that
essentially YouTube couldn't operate
under cover of darkness anymore with the
hearts of their policy and how they were
doing thing so the whole result of it
was that people got to see more of what
was actually happening again kind of
seeing the whole rice Berg but then the
other part was the number of times I've
run into people or like we were at the
am show and they said the turning point
for them and understanding and like
actually checking out the content yeah
was saying okay I saw the clip video
I've seen some of the tweets and the
stories I'm gonna go watch this for
myself
you're right thinking young adults you
know teenagers older adults who are all
saying I was like I'm gonna go check and
see whether what the news I'm being told
is correct so they went and watch the
videos and came away thinking I I'm
shocked I'm not already a subscriber
right right I signed up for monk well I
think three main points actually that I
wanted to touch on one was I'm actually
really grateful because they've already
done their legwork and trying to find
the best so so it's all out there watch
the box highlight reel there you go
worse to me baby the apology video which
was of course work which was insanely so
they did the highlight reel right and
that that sent more people to us at this
point and I think some of the did save
us with YouTube is word kind of two
things that you'll hear if you work in
this industry one is that we work harder
than every other program out there
everyone here works really hard I
wouldn't say I'm necessarily the most
talented or gifted person but I will say
that it's it's pretty known that I work
hard and everyone this team works hard
we always work hard another thing is
people know that we have more
subscribers than any other like
exclusive paid over-the-top service out
there period now it's well known that
your Mudd Club is the biggest appeared
outside of pornography in the early
aughts you guys have signed up on the
point where if YouTube were to have
removed us still many tens of thousands
of views would be on our response on mug
Club and that would look even worse yeah
so I think that forced the hand a little
bit where they were like oh you know if
we remove this this isn't someone's just
gonna go away with a few hundred people
who are gonna patreon these are a lot of
people who are going to be mobilizing
and I think the reason that we weren't
deep platformed was and it wasn't just
because of us trying to refuse to
apologize I apologize all the time when
I'm wrong yeah but we didn't we knew
that we weren't wrong and because of
your support we knew we had to do right
by you and stay stand fast and stand by
our principles and so the apology video
rather than a lot of people who either
apologized in a soft way or kind of make
it about please don't remove us we did
the apology video which was okay here
you go
it's only gonna get worse and what they
missed is that said Vox guys videos were
so horrible and that's what we were
commenting on and the entire thing and
it just kept coming back even though we
did plenty of rebuttals then I will say
this we didn't buddy on the box work
didn't involve this guy knows that we're
coming out there so bad that we were
just we had we had to respond to them
yeah okay and then that's the that's the
top set and then there's a plus-one this
is one I will personally a possibly
which personally apologize for because I
lied to you yeah I like know this b-roll
is or a clip that word clip okay
how long has a clip it's it's two
minutes oh so this controversy I will by
the way at the notification bell if
you're watching on YouTube because
apparently you know
descriptions don't mean a whole lot
right now hit all notifications and this
is a good time to tell you Crowder bits
is a channel where we upload other
content sketches all that kind of stuff
and of course iTunes I guess that's
Apple plain HOD Club is the main thing
but I lied to you guys for years
yeah years I usually would abused you
when I told you that we were and we
hashtag never daily that we were never
going to go daily with this show and I
did so and I would say that our
exploratory committee was definitely
never going to allow us to go daily full
disclosure I apologize I was doing that
all along
planning on going daily and you deserve
better but you didn't get it you got
daily instead and that's also something
a lot of people don't know if you're not
a member of mug Club you only get a clip
on YouTube but people at mug Club they
get after Wednesday they get all kinds
so this is this is the timeline of the
never daily yeah okay I apologize for
this I did it I was wrong I'm a work in
progress proudly introducing the month
ladder with Crowder has gotten daily
[Music]
we are too wild and overrated sketch on
it your schemes these screens not frozen
s1 and a mess with you guys you'll
notice it's very different there's no
standard intro for for today so that's
because this is the first installment of
a bot is bi-weekly ever of the week
taking your questions my girlfriend is 9
my girlfriend of 9 months thanks oh
thanks a lot for the small spot Johnny
boy a lot of a gap looking for dead
people
jeez where they said 14 euro this is
Faces of Death is this Nazi Germany
she's forgiven her husband after he
hired a hitman to kill her so she's
better at picking out husbands he's
really bad at picking out assassin yeah
we don't want to be hit you made up just
sit back and talk back can I have
harkens back to the radio days which is
when you say following our quarterback
Garrett everybody go up water and gel
blow smoke get me you little bastards
I'm gonna smell every joke that makes
the show every bit weird you say we
right we're off yeah like four five six
get cut like every day yes thank God he
has a Cortney player this year I'm not
throwing on YouTube would it would be
immediately demonetized let's have Grif
read numbers number six pitched Jeffrey
Epstein vehicles number six I can't read
[Music]
hey you know I'm actually gonna make the
first Thursday ever Ash Wednesday it
looks like a nice cigar - no it doesn't
celebratory is that the one that had the
electrical tape as a band it did yeah
yeah hold on a second someone else carry
the mic you're a bad one no bill so I
for people who don't haven't subscribed
to my club yet you're terrible but
second we love you anyway the fun thing
about the coronavirus hey hey hey mr. J
to receptors genetic proclivity toward
pandemics Trump once I have another
trade war with China we will keep
bringing the corona pipe Wow table so
the thing I love most about the the kind
of stuff that's behind the paywall and
in mug club this available is we heat a
lot more in depth we talk about a lot of
different topics we're really engaging
with a lot of different fan questions
and comments and stuff like that and you
really get to see another side of
everything that's done here yeah and
more more of what a lot of people like
about what they see on YouTube right but
like I said we can't do any of the rest
of it without mug club right now yeah
exactly no now I sorry I tossed that
thing it was gonna be a timeline of the
never Daly but we told you were never
going Daly for a long time and I will
tell you this the reason why all joking
aside was because we knew that at the
time we didn't have I knew that we
didn't have the capacity to do a daily
show yeah and so we launched an election
night when we were going daily that's
right you were with me that was a long
long night we're driving across the
country it was yes where we knew that if
we had enough signups and that was
actually a bit of a risk because we said
okay if we announce that we're going
daily maybe enough people will sign up
where we can afford the resources we
need to go data and we hit that number
within the first like four hours of
election night yeah and and again like i
io no percent of this and you know we
worked up CIT now you have a partnership
with the blaze where you get access to
all their catalog and of course they
help handle this this back-end these
apps that now work really well the blaze
app is just stuff that we were never
able to afford so we've been able to do
this without having to take money from
Al Jazeera yeah many times outside money
yeah that's something people understand
either it's you and then we have
partnership agreements you know where we
either give a percentage or get a
percentage yeah
from some other folks okay so we do have
to
go on a lot of Mont a lot of memorylanes
to stroll down here in the United States
it's gotta be at least one there's more
than 10 Street 10 maybe 12 we've done
these and actually will be releasing the
album soon everybody's gonna be at
Spotify or wherever but oh it's so buddy
we've done enough musical parodies we
started off where we would do them every
now and then yeah just intermittently
sometimes to be on a Thursday show
sometimes they'd be on a you know Monday
or Tuesday show behind the paywall you
know mug club and I know I saved my
calendar so I need to say cuz like you
haven't seen it but I'm talking about
this content right and then actually we
started doing more of them when audio
wade came in because the audio Wade
house killed singer and also able to
produce some music yeah and so before
that I would have to write all the
lyrics and then send up this other guy
unbelievable but he's abroad he's remote
and so it would take a long time so we
we started doing more of these musical
parodies and we hear you we appreciate
you we are always trying to do more of
them but again some of these music
videos take a lot of pretty you know so
what's your favorite track that we've
done as far as music um the what was the
one we did in the montage earlier where
I'm in the back playing the guitar the
part though it's one of my favorites
yeah yeah I'm was dr. Trump just because
the the car outrageous the lyrics were
awesome that was 30 so it was the
moonshot that here at the new studio
[Music]
subscribers audio wagered the music guy
I think Nirvana is my favorite one yeah
yeah yes and I do like a long time ago
because it's kind of raw I like the
rocket man kim jeong-hoon just because
that was awesome just because of Gerald
a as Dennis Rodman he looks so much like
a white Dennis Rodman
that we had you back on the show is
Dennis Rodman I'm into the show home
like I don't know what I don't know I
don't know how we get there yeah it ends
with Gerald a is Dennis Rodman yeah I
get to the studio and they're like yeah
you have a custom I'm like what I have a
what yeah
okay I drew in a correction my favorite
one is audio Wade and got an itch girl
probably watched it 50 times yeah I mean
also you got quarter black with the
swivel hips of course
I just forgot about that unfortunately
by their mother his hip oh yeah father
was awesome his hips are mostly straight
forward but occasionally they fit so
this is I hope you enjoy and let us know
what other musical parodies you would
like to see this is an episode where we
want to hear from you we want your
feedback and we want to see your
comments because that will help dictate
the direction of the show let us know
here our favorite musical parodies
[Music]
[Music]
with your seasoned
now welcome to a2 city I said welcome to
a2 city every place everywhere we go
yeah they wanna try to ban all show
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and there you would think I was the one
who was quarterblack no it's this one
and you just thought he was Mexican all
right we are going to have to go
actually to a commercial break really
quickly and if I should so this is where
we're gonna have our guests mark yes
have either sent in a video or we'll
call in here and I think we'll actually
have some videos from you before we go
into our favorite commercials we should
mention our sponsors of course Walter's
a wonderful sponsor they've been with us
for a long time and a black rifle coffee
unbelievable
I think expressvpn is more recent and a
building let me say but a long time ago
got dropped by audible so screw those
guys
[Laughter]
dropped so quickly he actually does what
it's a job security okay so enjoy the
commercials and here are some guests
[Music]
our world is increasingly ruled by
technology information moves faster than
the speed of light but how do you know
that you and your personal information
are safe that's why you should protect
yourself with the latest in cyber
security technology a sticky note are
you worried that it might leave you open
to hackers spies geo blocks IP detection
ad targeting NSA habit tracking traffic
logs third-party microphone access and
theft of your personal data we've got
you covered
with a sticky note and if you're
concerned about all that other stuff
there's always expressvpn Stephen
congratulations on an incredible
milestone when I first heard about it I
figured it was maybe a thousands episode
something like that but 1 billion views
that's the real deal man I'm surprised
that they're still allowing you on the
platform frankly well it just goes to
show you what you can achieve with a
little bit of effort ingenuity and a
small rent-free space in your parents
basement I suppose we all need our
hobbies Stephen Mahmoud here from Isis
headquarters to wish you congratulations
on your one billionth murder what do you
mean do you
you go congratulations on getting a
billion downloads or views or whatever a
grown man
having your daddy call people to
congratulate you and tell you good job
congratulations on what I hear is one
billion people that are now watching
your steaming program Crowder run
chowder that's quite an achievement
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
well the coffee is delicious but you
should should still keep your eyes on
the road really happy to announce our
latest sponsor black rifle coffee and
the company does more than just coffee
by the way they're veteran owned and
operated and they actually still
actively serve those in the veteran
community today so all of November for
every bag or box of coffee rounds that
you purchase black rifle coffee will
donate another bag to active deployed
members of our armed services and
something else unlike other companies
who claim small batch or premium coffee
black rifle coffee isn't roasted until
after you place your order which is
really important a lot of people don't
know this coffee is a bean and like
other beans and legumes I'm not exactly
sure what that is a legume but it goes
bad right so if you've been drinking
stale coffee tastes the difference for
yourself and support a company it has
the best product out there and does a
lot of good work go to black rifle
coffee comm slash Crowder and if you
enter crowd or as a discount code you'll
receive 20% off your first order black
rifle comm black rifle coffee comm slash
Crowder almost got it
but now you've been allowed to over a
billion listeners this is crazy my
friend you know what you are telling the
truth and the truth will set this
country free congratulations up to 2
billion woo congratulations from the
Walford family keep up the good work and
keep defending our right
I guess the billion is good I mean it
means quality all you need to do is look
at the McDonald's sign to realize that a
billion is the number you're aiming for
but I'm happy for you on it may not be
happier if it was my channel that had a
million views but I'm happy for you
because you have me on your show
everyone here at Walter arms
to everybody there a lot with Crowder
congratulations on 1 billion views your
1 billionth view and I just want to say
truly from the bottom of my heart this
is a sign of the end of days I believe
this is actually in the Bible you were
mentioned by name
[Music]
tell me what does that magnificent hand
etched mug do that well that
unfortunately is mug Club the current
our existence and the objective of your
next mission seem a lot has been
spreading truth entertainment and
encouraging the American Way
furthermore even more alarmingly they've
been able to bypass our assistance from
the YouTube census able to reach
communicate with their listeners
directly your objective will be to find
who is at the center of this mug club
extract any information by any means
necessary and destroy it
[Music]
Stephen Congrats on 1 billion views just
to be clear that's not even a fraction
of the world population so it's Steven
Crowder congratulations on passing over
a billion views despite shadow banning
censorship and all the attacks you've
gone through but I am here to criticize
you it's not a good thing to joke around
and have humor it hurts a lot of
people's feelings that can be confused
when you told me you were gonna get to a
billion views I didn't believe you but
then you explained it was really simple
all you needed was a Russian bot farm
and you could have artificial views into
the billions and I gotta say it is
remarkable crowded doc we interviews
what a pile of crap that is only because
he's paying Google off it hey Steven
congratulations hi Steven how are you
doing a billion 1 billion YouTube views
I'm just sitting down here in my
basement bunker thank you so much to
everybody thank you Rand Paul thank you
my hell my mood thank you Jim Koepp
Thank You Glenn Beck thank you more
crypto Jacko Jim Norton dang I already
said Ted Cruz said it again and during
the break my Asian lawyer bill Richman
said I couldn't get 2 billion yeah
really
couldn't I think we're gonna skip it I
think that's why I said it yeah it's
gonna go to three your lightest capaz
right there 245 well and by the way we
are also going it we're gonna do a
special live stream live with your
tweets when we pass the enteric
subscribers because they've never talked
about them again because you cannot
punch it down and this is one thing to
when we say a billion views in this
channel you said it's closer to two if
you add up mug Club the rest of it this
is with one piece of content on YouTube
per day it's not like a lot of these
other networks that are doing 50 pieces
or 30 pieces and like this is really
what's incredible we are so grateful and
a big part of this we will say that
bring the big part that brings in the
most amount of new subscribers here on
YouTube because you know search results
we've talked about a lot of these
algorithms aren't necessarily favorable
to us we've had a lot of problems
running our ceiling
yeah the problem is like how do we reach
new audiences right well people search
steven crowder changement mine for the
longest dozen kind of fix didn't didn't
show up yeah and then we were no longer
able to like run videos as ad so since
like how do you reach new people the
thing that does cut through and helps us
reach new people more than anything else
are what we call sort of super videos
and these are videos are we going
location like anta foe we've talked
about yeah and there are two two really
ones that stick out changed my mind is
absolutely within the last three or four
years and then a subsidiary of that
Crowder confronts which usually occurred
because someone threatened to kill me to
change my mind the fight for one so but
these super videos what often happens is
they go viral they sort of become a news
stories opposed to commenting on the
news you know they became a news story
in and of themselves and that ultimately
leads to more people subscribing to the
channel and here's the thing I
appreciate how much everyone out there
understands sometimes if you join my
club we'll have like a week where we
maybe miss two shows right so usually
we'll pre-tape but sometimes we can't we
just have to run and go do a
hidden-camera deal where we don't have a
hundred and forty something writers or
staff like yeah Jay Leno has or a
hundred something like Seth Meyers have
we we have twelve people here and I
think fifteen is an account part-timers
abroad and so we just have to pack up
everything go out and tape a super video
where we can't do this show and that and
we would never be able to afford to do
these super videos if not for you I mean
to give you an idea doing like to change
my mind you'll see in front of the White
House that's getting twelve people to
Washington DC several hundred pounds of
equipment making sure that we have
security when we get there getting
travel back not to mention the editing
software food hotel typically for two
days I mean you're talking about tens of
thousands of dollars often to do these
and we wouldn't be able to do it if not
for mug club and I know it's one of
those things that sometimes you don't
see because these go up on YouTube but
mutt club is paying for that it's paying
for us to reach new people because that
cuts through the algorithms and I can't
thank you enough we've actually shot a
few that are in the hopper and we're
planning on doing more of these in the
coming coming year coronavirus has made
it a little bit tough you know eggs
let's go right now to a montage of
actually top moments from funded by you
on location super videos thanks again so
much hi my name is Steven Crowder
[Music]
you want the Vitis he will not divide us
what do you think would happen if we
went into a Muslim bakery and asked for
a gay wedding you can write on it Ben
loves Stephen forever and have our hands
may be holding can I get a gun here
without a background check I thought a
gun shows you didn't have to do a
background check
well you're asking it was it because of
the magazine capacity no okay yeah it
does look really sinister would you be
on board with common sense gun reform
that's what that means
do you own any firearms shotgun well
sorry welcome to Detroit
[Music]
we have a nice two-story in the Detroit
area cozy rustic
you guys have papers I need papers he's
new collaging mother
waiter these hobos get a load of be my
walls not a price that you're willing
yes that yes [ __ ] yes [ __ ] slag
are you familiar with the term
manspreading we'll see what women think
using our homemade apparatus I get one
yeah
I've decided to go through the
socialized Canadian healthcare system
to show you exactly what it's really
like once finished that means we wait
and we get judged decide how important
here hold up a government employee
recommending a private clinic we've been
tracking it for a long time he was just
down there at president's circle and
they were handing out sharp objects to
staff people with so they had someone
coming with an 8k why did it take - late
night hosts comedians to find this out
we took a hidden camera to an abortion
clinic in Colorado where late term
abortions have been legal for years to
show you exactly what it is that they we
and you are talking about it all this
woman was going to end her 32 week
that's eight months her eight months old
baby's life
sometimes like to thank you they did
this
[Music]
hi I'm Stephanie with all the
frequencies of a feminism
hold on you see I'm Stephanie and I'm
pretty sure I'm pregnant really wanted
to talk wasn't about plan B
[Music]
ladder with really nice mug not cheap
mugs
nice mug people are triggered hey
YouTube what you're about to watch is a
new segment we call change my mind
pretty simple we go out and set up in
public and pick a topic and we actually
allow people from other points of view
to come up and proactively change my
mind you are more than welcome to change
my mind if you think I'm wrong I am open
to having my mind changed fetus is
literally a parasite like it is sucking
the life from a mother yeah every single
day like that's literally what happens
that's not even like not a mother I'm
guessing
[Music]
would you be willing to maybe in a
follow-up we could do a segment on this
go with me to arrange shoot for the
first time
[Music]
[Music]
you gotta connect all the way around
look at this table out there look at
this
all different races genders the power of
dance of course there are always those
who aren't so excited to see all the
racist steven crowder y'all I would
probably punch him if I saw
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
mainly to perfect women period so you
should respect women I am a woman so
[ __ ] you might be for cancer if we want
to sit down with people in an ideal
scenario and be able to exchange ideas
but when they don't want to and they're
acting like little spoiled brat slash
domestic terrorists we've got to make
them afraid of some body take it
you want a piece of me for a long time
hey how are you man
steven crowder what's going on Vince my
son he follows my son when I said you
didn't even post this and acted like you
didn't know me I think you're a liar
what do you mean by that weird like what
you meant with killing members of ice
and we going here I do want to let you
guys know the promo code is crowder
billion you get $20 off and all that by
the way is was funded by you like some
of those I couldn't see the progression
the Muslim bakery was literally a friend
acting like he was on his phone right
early on we missed a lot of filming
because we didn't have changed my mind
Crowder confronts all you can see the
progression was all because of Mudd Club
so we do ask you because there can be
another box apocalypse Crider billion
get $20 off and the change my mind
things are stemmed from sitting down me
going like oh we have so many good
conversations but off air right yeah
we've done plenty of debates on this
show on air by the way change my mind is
not a debate we just made I wish we
could just talk with normal people
without doing political sort of
point-scoring in a quadrant view yeah
and we did not think at this point every
single person who was involved with
content and we floated the idea said
there's no way that'll work yeah that'll
never work
edited and long just people talking no
one will watch this to the point where I
feel lazy when I do it because I'm like
I don't want to do another change my
mind because I want to do something new
and then you guys obviously want us to
do it so that's like I've said I want to
provide you with what it is that you
want and do some new things but I really
am grateful we have everyone here that
met everyone they all get to work with
the show let me ask you a half-asian
bill what would you like what
what do you think is next what would you
like to see next for this show I'd say
more of the content we're already doing
getting more around the country seeing
more of the fans we've got fans all over
the world I know we were I think just
this week making fun of the University
of Western Australia and I saw a number
of comments of students yeah as a
University of Washington Western
Australians who are like ding man can't
afford those carbonyls the fires are
down it's right no III think doing more
of that content and being able to get
around the country is the number one and
more of it would be more exciting for
everyone and I just love the energy and
the sense of community that people have
to be able to just hear some great
viewpoints some honest feedback and some
hilarious we need enough of you to join
so we can get a plane actually I'm only
half joking because sometimes we do the
live shows it ends up costing less less
to rent a plane we don't get jets but
like a bread like we get like a
turboprop yeah to get all of our team
out in all this equipment because you
talk about so much to go to campus so
obviously we don't expect you to pay for
a Learjet but we can travel to Australia
if you know we can take a week off yeah
a show cuz that's a lot of travel I
think we're gonna send actually even
Brendan on that flight from Sydney to
Buenos Aires with a GPS just to prove
that the earth is not flat but he just
found out right now yeah I want to
concur but for another reason like it
gets you an opportunity like my favorite
memory of everything that's ever been
done with this show was when we did the
first thing at SMU the four was at the
Halloween spooktacular
I can't remember which one it was right
but it was the first time and you filled
the auditorium and that was just such a
big moment but it happened they all
filled the auditor made it happen I mean
I know we I want to be clear there's no
way I could have ever done this show
that scale like at SMU in real life or
the school I had done stand-up before it
I may go back to doing some more
stand-up in small clubs we've talked
about this when I have more free time
could not have done it without this team
of people there's so much that goes into
it what's the insurance writer like a
million dollars just an equipment with
yeah be there
day and a half in advance so that's just
that's not false humility I am so
grateful to know to do that kind of show
because it was in here but I could never
make it here and everyone here and you
get to see fans because you deal with a
lot of people pushing back on you right
and left like you get us obviously but
everybody else seems to be trying to
attack you in different ways and so it's
great to be around fans but it's also
great for them because they get to be
around a bunch of other people that are
exactly like them they're conservative
people when it's not popular to be
conservative and so it's great for both
that we get to do those live events so
let's get it done at Notre Dame let's go
there Notre Dame Notre Dame Aires a long
time yeah before this show was daily and
I remember there were like 400 people
who showed up yeah and I thought that
was all the people in the world back
there was just me doing stand-up and
some kids showed up and half the
questions at the Q&A were about my time
being the brain and Arthur my catalog
well thank you guys all very much and we
do have to get going that that promo
code is crowder billion to get $20 off
and you know I will say in watching that
there have been some things obviously
we've created we're proud of the intros
and the change my mind and that's
probably something I'm pretty proud of
because I see a lot of other people
trying to do it do the change my mind
and approaching conversations in that
way in real life and and if I can serve
to help you with that and help equip you
with that in a way that professors have
failed you
then I'm grateful but I was even
watching that you know that that lady at
the abortion clinic we never talked to
that she didn't have that abortion
really shouldn't have that abortion
that's me we couldn't show that in the
video because we didn't want to this was
actually it was a real kind of moral
dilemma because we're going well you
know what's more important is is it
stopping this abortion of this woman is
getting anyway or is it showcasing the
horrors of abortion so that thousands of
other people don't important what we did
was with my permission some of the girls
who went in undercover
I said they knew she was going in like
the next week for the abortion I said
we're gonna release this video before
then so don't reach out to her right now
let us release this so we you know we
can still serve this purpose and get
this out to the pub and then I want you
to reach out to her yeah and I don't
know exactly what happened but I do know
that that woman did not have that
abortion and we also had that girl who
we did the change my mind with who came
back on the show and then she was
pro-life yeah
it's seen those things like that that
really make those the change our minds
in the super videos kind of more
important you know yes it's doing
something for the wall and also when I
look back and see that that one where I
was shooting at the range that I sounded
like death warmed over all of the above
and I was at a gun range with nothing
but gunpowder and we know that's what's
great about you though is even whenever
you're down and you're sick or or you're
really stressed out or there's bigger
things going on you're always really
focused and able to do what you need to
do so yeah we forced you to work with me
I can build a meet and pyramid as well
but who knew and then those girls tried
to buy that firearm you know they wanted
of course they wanted to Walter yes I
will tell you this we didn't lead them
we let them try a Walther Glocks
different firearms and they all
preferred the Walther I will just say
try the welfare and then they couldn't
purchase it because they weren't 21 for
a handgun yeah but afterwards they'd
change their view completely that you
can just purchase a gun without a
background check
right and then in close I will say you
know I mean I was just seeing kind of
hopper and there I was like I kind of
tucked in my heart Street but and I
appreciate by the way the support like
yeah I get a lot of pushback I think a
lot of times people focus on haters or
they focus on negativity and and you get
that when you're in the public sphere
right you get a lot of people aim that
at you but it is so far outweighed I
would say by what we do here by how many
lives that we see we've we've touched
how much this show means to you guys and
honestly you mean every bit as much to
us you know I would say more to me when
I look at the billion I go oh my gosh
this is what these people are choosing
to tune into this one at a time when
media is so fractured at a time where
you have a million different options at
any given moment when we thought media
was getting too fractured because of
cable because of dish or like people
have like 200 stations well now there's
yeah 200 more just in that pause yeah
we're just created and the fact that you
choose and one thing to like people at
you to people in these social media
consulting companies they often look at
our numbers and they're dumbfounded at
the number of people who just come in
every day to watch our videos whether
you're subscriber or not and so we've
been able to survive a lot of these
algorithms it's a changing landscape
because of your loyalty and
and I hope that we've earned it I hope
that we have billions more and this
really means this really means a lot to
me the show I don't mean the billion
views just the show being able to do
this and I will do it as long as I can
and my body allows which you know may
not be that long because I'm not only on
the FBI Isis kill list I'm on the
premium frequent-flyer list so Thank You
Walter we appreciate your security
health promo code is crowder billion we
are going to be releasing some super
videos here coming up next week we'll be
back to our regular schedule thank you
so much I look forward to reading your
comments and
[Music]
you
you